hi so I'm here to talk about the gdpr
and I assume that the people here who
are interested in it know what the GDP
is it's okay if you haven't not everyone
has to at this point in time but if you
haven't heard anything about it well
done for coming and if you really have
absolutely no idea I'll be the one to
inform you 2016 GDP are as an asteroid
on its way to collide with the mainland
Europe on the 25th of May 2008 so you've
got about a month to go in an
astonishing coincidence the European
Parliament also passed a law called the
GD P R and it is set to take effect on
and I'm not making this up on the 25th
of May 2018 so you've got about a month
to go for that for my own sake I'm going
to ignore the asteroid completely and
just focus on the hypothetical peaceful
life in the European unit afterwards
also I'm an Australian and I'm probably
going to say data not data there's
nothing I can do about that I'm gonna
try my best so what is the GD P R it
basically regulates the processing of
personal data you've probably already
been doing this for a while because we
already have laws that do that this time
around it seems to be a little bit
different the scope and the enforcement
of the laws is dramatically increased
for example the the punishment of the 4%
of your global annual revenue is scary
and so more people are talking about it
taking it seriously and we're here where
we are now the other bit that's very
interesting is that it's a regulation
and the old one was just a directive so
it means that all over Europe it's
exactly the same it's the same text
translated in several languages whereas
previously each country had their own
little legislation and they had their
own little authority to control it and
they may or may not have been
very serious about doing that properly
as a user this is actually quite
wonderful and much-needed and because of
the recent happenings with Facebook and
Cambridge analytical and so on we're all
starting to see that this is actually
quite nice you may have already had this
warm feeling of trust when you have been
seeing these consent forms explaining to
in full detail in plain text what
they're going to do with your data and
you feel that you have this list this
this is knowledge that it's going to be
deleted whenever you want and everything
is happy
not sure if that feeling is valid the
GDP I ever feel feel free to read
through it it's not too hard to get into
it's a large a document but the
beginning is some recitals they're not
part of the lore the first 30 years so
pages then we have some articles which
are the binding bits only the first 34
are really relevant to us after that it
starts setting up some regulatory bodies
and Nayla and we'll go through some of
these sections just quickly so you'll
have a clear group of that and then
towards the end there are a couple more
that are slightly interesting but it's
not too scary it is accessible the IC
our website has in the UK has a very
nice sort of introduction to a lot of
these things and I'm sure you'll hear
about it Lots in the next in next time
I'm here to talk not to two managers or
people running companies I'm here to
talk to developers data scientists and
engineers and for you you've got a
little bit more relaxed because you're
not personally reliable for anything
under the GDP are your companies if
you're an employee if you're a
freelancer you are I'm sorry but if
you're an employee you'll be fine
basically it's up to your company to
train you to to give you these skills
and knowledge and they're the ones that
carry the responsibility
what I'm going to do is is I'll give you
a quick overview of what I expect
professional software developers or data
scientists to be doing and what was just
mentioned before I think there is a
professional duty for anyone who calls
themselves a data scientist or a
software engineer to get to know these
these rules of engagement these rules
that define how you work it's not a
legal requirement to know this but I
think it's a professional requirement
and we don't have that formal
requirement as as doctors and lawyers
and other professions do and I think
it's a shame but I think it's good and
it also makes you a little bit more
valuable to your employer if you ask
someone who does know all of these
things more importantly though is that
this really helps your employer compart
and comply with the legislation with the
regulation because you're in a position
where you know the data far better than
the people who make the decisions about
the gdpr and you'll see a lot more
things that they'll never see and you'll
probably also understand how your
algorithms and data works and you'll be
able to notice a lot of areas where
compliance may disappear so what I will
do is I'll go through these what those
three things that were on the board but
not anymore basically the terms order
spaces and concepts that the that are in
the legislation you'll get to know about
all of them personal data processing
data control all that sort of thing I'll
go through some of the rights that users
have or you as well as a user when
you're using other sites and at the end
the third the the last third I'll be
looking at some tasks and things that
actually we have to do and we have to
know about to do differently when
looking at terms I think one sort of
thing to think about is that there are
no clear answers for what is personal
data what is a controller and this and
then some are more clear than others but
it's not really like programming there
types there are no sets of sort of data
we say a name is personal data and a
religion is it doesn't really work like
that at all
in in law you sort of have to argue for
one thing or you can argue for another
sometimes the context means that this is
personal data sometimes it doesn't mean
it's personal data so when we do look at
personal data what is it it's a very
very broad definition that just as any
information relating to an identified
identifiable natural person so it
explicitly mentions indirect
identification and there are some
examples later on they talk about things
that you could identify someone not
directly but through other factors and
it also mentions in a longer definition
in this section the an online identifier
like an IP address like a device code
like a like your cookies they all
qualify as personal data because you can
I use them to identify somebody names
can sometimes not be our personal data
they mostly are IP addresses can also
not be but they mostly are it depends on
a case-by-case basis and you'll know it
when you see it because you'll ask
yourself the question can it identify
someone the data subject is just what we
call the person whose data is the
personal data that's a pretty simple one
processing comes up a lot what that
means is really broad as well that's
basically any of this so collecting
recording organize instructing storage
and update I mean anything you pretty
much do with data note that it doesn't
cover everything and there are a lot of
exceptions for example if you write some
notes if you don't intend to file those
notes than that of some exception you
don't need to concern yourself with a
lot of that basically think processing
is anything anything you do with
personal data also note well I mean when
we talk about a data controller I guess
that'll come up a data controller and
the data processor which is after that
those are the two entities which do
something with data so the first one is
is pretty much the one that takes the
data from here usually and they sort of
control the purposes of what they're
going to do with it
and the processor is just someone who
works on the data if there are
exemptions as well to this one for
example just your friends are sharing
phone numbers if it's purely personal
that's not going to be a problem you're
not a data controller you're safe and if
you're something like a freelancer then
you you're also not a data controller
because you're not you're just working
with your clients data this is also very
broad it also includes people outside of
the EU you were working with European
data that's also not a concern for us
technical technical people the data
processor is like a freelancer I will be
a processor if I work on a client's data
they are the ones who are controlling it
but I also have some obligations less
obligations but some multiplications
special categories is the second last
thing that you probably should know
about what these are are a broad range
of sensitive personal data things so for
example ethnic origin political opinions
and so on you should get to know these
because you'll need to recognize them
you're probably the only ones that will
see if this data sneaks its way into
your system also notice that the word
revealing means that it's not always
direct the data may sort of slide into
your system because something else will
reveal it and your bosses your anyone
who's in control of running the product
and this and that may not know that this
happening it may only be you who can see
it and you really should there are of
course exceptions and this and that but
you should maybe flag it and let the
people know about it who'd want to know
about it that it's happening data that
comes under this will have a special
have some extra requirements for storing
it safely separating it maybe and also
as we'll see
and automatic decision-making cannot
discriminate using any of these
categories profiling is the last one
that's just a special form of processing
that's called out by name it can have
effect on transparency requirements it's
not too important for for us as as
people working with the data but it is
something we sort of need to get to know
about it just it is it is what it is you
analyzing data on a person to predict or
analyze their performance at work
economic situation health preferences
that's also very very broad pretty much
I struggle to think of an example that
that isn't profiling if you're
predicting something about somebody if
you come up with one we know it's
deliberately broad and it has a few
other meanings in the the the law if you
get to know that it'll help but moving
on very quickly because I want to get to
some technical things here are some of
the rights that uses that us when we're
a user that we get to enjoy transparency
is what you may have already noticed the
company is telling you what they're
doing with their data from which you
didn't know about before and this is
really fun to sort of read these
disclosures they're in plain text
they're very short and simple and you
have to explicitly consent to them this
is all wonderful but not exactly our
concern you can sort of see some
companies testing the limits and they'll
be lit they'll probably be some
litigation on that later it's not so
much our issue access to data is also as
a user interesting we get to see what
they have on us and and download it and
this and that it's not quite an inner
data science perspective not quite
important for us but we can
I will talk about this more at another
conference for web developers so if you
do the web development it can be
something for you you have to allow your
users to rectify to correct data that's
wrong you have to allow them to erase
their data on request that is if they
remove their consent or they object to
it if you have other reasons for doing
it you have to think about whether you
can do that whether you're able to
delete just a single users data
throughout all of your systems on
request you've got a month to do it if
they ask you to data portability is the
same thing this is more interesting and
I wonder what that'll end up being you
have to provide your users or your
people with data subjects with their
data in a structured commonly used in
machine readable format have fun when
you there is also maybe the requirement
that you send it off to another provider
if you're in a web development context
that's more interesting to you you have
to be able to restrict processing of
data if someone says please don't
continue processing that you have to
have some flag or something to stop that
single bit of data being used but not
delete it there are the possibility that
someone requests to be opted out of
automated decision-making you have to
allow that good luck and the right to
object is is I guess I should have
included that in a racer above it's the
same sort of thing but it just it's
another legal situation where that
arises now is the more interesting that
the the bit about the the things we have
to do the way our job is changed and a
lot of this isn't clear yet the law is
new it hasn't even happened yet but no
one really knows exactly how it'll be
interpreted a lot of the things are a
bit broader than they were before we're
going to have to suffer a little bit in
that in the changeover we're going to
have to do things that are uncomfortable
and maybe rewrite systems or learn new
tools or write new tools to manage our
data and it's going to hurt us a little
bit but I guess in the future in five
years this will all be a bit more
commonplace
we'll be easier we'll know exactly what
we'll need to do and we'll know the best
ways of addressing a lot of these things
one vague requirement of the law is
privacy or protection of data by design
and by default that means that you have
to be good at what you do to use
state-of-the-art encryption and and do
things properly and separate your system
what that sort of means is I guess to
separate your your personal data from
the rest of your system that's the
easiest way to do it to not sort of mix
personal data within the rest of your
business logic helps you protect it a
little bit that's one way of designing
your systems to to work with that
encrypt sensitive data of those special
categories so that you don't
accidentally pass that around the
company and maybe track the purpose for
which you've got consent of a lot of
this personal data it's not clear
exactly what that is going to entail but
you sort of have a vague idea as someone
technical how you might be able to make
sure personal data doesn't fly around
the system in plain text I've already
said all of that I believe yeah exactly
a ratio is then the same thing the same
problem someone comes to you and says
please remove all of my data can you do
that if you're developing a system you
might have backups of your data that
could automatically encrypted and sent
somewhere can you remove a single user
from that data not so easy but if you're
separating a personal data from your
other backups there may be ways of doing
that you have one month to react if you
have database dumps you probably don't
need them for 28 days database dump is a
way of very quickly putting data back
into a database do you need to do that
28 days with old data is there a way
that you could maybe just remove
personal data from the database backups
and in that case just delete the
personal data after 28 days or archive
it in a machine-readable format that you
have to give the users anyway try and
try and automate some of these things
try and work it into your workflow if
you're a data scientist you might be
working with systems that aren't always
your systems into control of so I guess
you have to have your own ways of doing
this but maybe if you do get too much
data if you do get all this sensitive
data when you're trying to work on
something that has nothing to do with it
you could ask questions about why you've
been given this data you probably
wouldn't want to have it if you encrypt
the data per user
note that encrypting something and
throwing away the key is deleting it and
if you crypt encrypt backups per user
you don't actually have to change the
backup you just throw away the key for
that user and it means you haven't
haven't messed with your data in any
sense you haven't had to edit any of the
data if your systems also like that you
can do exactly the same and you've
managed to delete something without
changing anything in your system moving
on to something that we just heard about
discrimination via article 22 is now
banned for the special categories now
this isn't everything that is
discrimination the special categories
are the ones we had before racial ethnic
something that's missing from there is
six and age so you're free to
discriminate with your shoelaces you're
free to write pricing algorithms if you
automatically come up with those you're
not going to be hid under the GDP M
you'll probably be hid under some other
anti-discrimination legislation which is
I think it's just a bit bit lazy that
they reuse the same categories for
discrimination as they were for special
sensitive data but in again the
important word here is revealing and
that sort of suggests that this might be
indirect discrimination as well as
direct discrimination as was mentioned
before a post code can be revealing of
race and
it can also be personally identifying if
you combine it with the birthdays or
something like that I'll talk about that
in a minute if we get to two to
anonymizing data but if you discriminate
based on if you avoid discrimination
directly based on your protected
categories you may end up in trouble
because of things like intersectional so
my data doesn't discriminate against a
race or against gender but gender is not
included but if someone happens to be in
both those categories it may end up
being that your algorithm is
discriminating against those people and
that's not allowed so if you are testing
your systems for discrimination make
sure you don't forget intersectional
categories because you may miss them be
careful of uncertainty bias a lot of
minorities may be underrepresented in
your data and if you have sort of like a
risk-averse system that sort of sees
this uncertainty and then denies maybe a
loan application then you're going to be
in trouble because all those people in
that minority are never going to have
the certainty in your model to get over
that hurdle with indirect discrimination
that's that's tricky like that is and
and I hope you're all paying attention
in the talk before me because it's it is
very hard especially with the large data
sets to avoid discrimination creeping
through other unrelated seemingly
unrelated attributes one way of maybe
tackling this or there are several ways
of taking this one way of taking this
may be auditing maybe having an external
person with access to the protected
categories data while you have because
you haven't collected data on race and
gender and and so on another way is to
maybe make trade-offs as was mentioned
before discrimination doesn't cost the
world it it may it is in not very nice
to have a completely unfair system and
if it only costs you a small amount of
Optima of optimization then it's
probably not worth it and that that's a
problem of multiple optimization you if
you include it in in how your model
evaluates your data then maybe it will
be sort of included in that you don't
discriminate again a problem with that
is that you're not collecting data on on
race you're not collecting this data in
the first place it may be difficult to
audit yourself yeah it's it's hard to
say how this will be enforced in and we
can't really predict that now and I
think in a few years it may be a bit
clearer to what extent discrimination is
a problem
one thing is class actions are possible
under the GDP are so this enforcement
can be very heavy and it's not just
controlled from above it can be some
people really notice that your algorithm
is discriminating against them and
they're able to launch class actions
also if I go quickly back to the
discrimination this is only for
discrimination is only for completely
automated decisions made by systems if
you write your systems in a way that
allows the user to to be opt into to
have a person involved in the process
then you might be able to reduce the
discrimination it's hard to say what's
required of you and that will be clear
in the next few years but be aware that
this is something that you may have to
think about and if you attend
conferences like this you're in a good
position to address that the next one is
also very interesting it may be that
there is a requirement to explain
decision making this automated decision
making
it's not clear if that's the case
there's an argument for and against that
as lawyers like to argue it's not going
to be this or that I'm sorry it's not
going to be clear for a while
but I think it'll happen pretty quickly
there are a few companies that are
pushing the limits like roofer in
Germany and they'll be sued very quickly
and we might get a result on how how
much explaining we have to do but of
course if you have a nice neural network
with several deep layers good luck
trying to explain to the user how you
came up with that decision especially if
if the decision was made a long time ago
there's no real time limit that's
obvious that the user will come and say
to you okay a little while ago you made
this decision about me I'd like you to
explain what happened there are you able
to explain a decision made six months
ago this is an emerging area of research
and it's exciting and it's sort of
interesting to see how clever approaches
do that again it's really not clear if
that is a requirement except if you're
in Germany it is a requirement they have
a special law that increases the
coverage of the gdpr and there you do
have to explain it's not clear exactly
what you have to do there already
existed a rule like that sure for the
credit agency I mentioned in Germany
they got around that by having a token
person involved in their process who
pushed a button and so it wasn't a
completely automated process and they
were able to get away with not having to
explain what they're doing some people
in Germany where there definitely is
that explanation say that you roughly
maybe have to include the top four
reasons or most persuasive parts or
attributes or what was relied on to make
the decision this is all really hard to
do for some particular types of machine
learning again you're going to have to
wait and see a little bit but be
prepared get to know this emerging area
of research to see how your systems are
might be able to come up with
explaining something you'll have to
speak to the lawyers about when that
will actually be very required of you
anonymizing data so one interesting
thing is if you're not amazed your data
it's no longer personal data and it
means that the gdpr doesn't apply
anymore so beforehand if you collect
data with a purse specific reason to
purpose to use the data you can only use
it for that purpose or if you can think
of another legal reason to be able to
use that data that restriction is
removed as soon as you anonymize the
data sounds all nice and easy but
anonymizing data is actually very tricky
if you're not an expert in this or you
haven't really had much to do with
anonymizing data don't try to do it
yourself learn about it or find an
expert and get them into it basically
the test is if real identification is
reasonably likely and you are the people
who probably there are only people in
the organization who will know if it's
reasonably likely to be the data to be
read identify the lawyers or other
people involved in your gdpr for your
organization may have no idea how this
is when this is going to be a case again
you'll know that you have to be careful
if you're adding data sets you can
suddenly reify data you thought you'd
anonymized Facebook wanted to get some
medical data in the US because they knew
they were able to re-identify it and
link it to their existing data set you
have to assume that anyone who does if
there is a data breach that they will
have access to other data sets when you
try to anonymize it's as I said
especially for machine learning where
high dimensionality is very common
because we can now this is hard this is
really not going to be an easy thing to
do what can you do about it well if you
don't know what those three things are
at the top then you shouldn't be trying
any of this you should find someone and
they'll probably a lot of people in this
room who can do it for you or learn
about it but in general you can try
things like suspiration and
generalization avoid outliers as they
can they can reveal things but they're
also outliers are bad for your model as
well they can cause over fear they can
so a lot of this anonymization can
actually help improve your model get
help I guess and build it into your
systems if you have if you work a lot
with different teams and different data
maybe find automated ways of getting
access to data that that already caters
for anonymization through automatic
processes that can analyze it and then
give you or your data process that
you're handing the data off to some data
that's a bit safer to use in terms of
specific requirements of the law
basically if you start wanting to use
the data for anything for any purpose
you'll need to anonymize that and that's
that's the freedom it gives you breach
notification is pretty easy this is
something you need to know about because
if you do notice any unauthorized or
accidental breach of your data security
you need to have it notified within 72
hours this depends as well on this and
this and that but just make sure your
lawyers know about it so that someone
can do the notification because if you
tell nobody if you don't tell your
superiors you may put your company in
breach of the regulation basically
that's all I really had to sort of
quickly say about these issues it's not
in depth it's not giving you all of the
answers but it just gives you a feeling
for what you need to care about learn
some of those topics at the beginning
and get to know some of the rights and
the tasks you have you sort of know
where you can look for more information
try not to do everything yourself and
good luck because the nothing's really
clear at the moment and it will be maybe
in five years that we're the ones are
going to suffer the most right now thank
you
there any questions I'm not going to
answer questions on compliance or help
you comply in any way but if you have
general philosophical questions I'm
happy to thank you okay I work with open
data quite a lot and even if you don't
work with open data you might have data
that you've collected with consent or
then published in form that other people
can download does it does it apply to
that and does one have to be able to be
can a person asked to be deleted from
open datasets that they're consented to
be passed on but are now distributed um
tricky question it is a little bit on
compliance but if you are processing
data and you didn't really collect the
data or determine the purpose that's
then you're a processor so they're the
data subject doesn't contact you
directly they contact the controller so
whoever collected the data and they have
to contact you to erase the data but you
still need to have legal justification
to work on that data so ask your lawyers
to look through the sections that give
you the legal justification that will be
either explicit consent or if there's a
reason there are main the possibility of
data archival people or journalism that
could be exempted and that is in the
local laws possibly but you'll have to
to check that for you specific situation
it depends but generally if it's
anonymized data it's not personal data
in your free
but it applies to all data it applies to
anything you can all personal data that
you can identify somebody with unless
there's an exception unless there if you
can't identify it anymore yes hi yeah
thank you for the talk this my first
question may sort of breach into the
compliance issue but I'm assuming that
the sort of explaining why decisions
were made doesn't like just saying that
well we used machine learning and it
told us this is not really a valid
explanation so can you say anything
about what that sort of what the what
kind of form should that explanation
take yep and then the second question is
do you see any like unintended
consequences from gdpr that may arise
select for example example I do you have
any like oh dude you can you see any
like unintended consequences that could
arise from from gdpr
maybe so for the first question that was
about explanations and what that looks
like nobody knows it it's not clear
whether it's a general explanation like
this is basically how my system works we
take in these categories and that's or
if it's a specific explanation this is
your decision and this is what we used
exactly for your decision it's not clear
and it's most difficult especially when
you're using machine learning because it
it's very hard to do i I can't really
say what's going to happen we're going
to have to find out and it's I'm sorry
that it is that way in Germany that it
is a little bit more pronounced because
they were specifically saying there is
this riot of explanation and it's going
to look like this it may be that there
is no right to explanation because it
seemed to have been deliberately left
out of a specific article that was
mentioning it and it may have been a
little bit of politics that led to that
happening
yes question in front of you just from
the right fit
thanks we'll talk what happens to data
that is personally identifiable but that
is put on a public website that gets
taken down what happens that does
anybody that have has ended up reading
the state and possibly save this data
need to immediately delete it from the
data set or I should I've no idea how
that works in practice but basically the
controller who put the data up on the
website has to make sure that anyone
that they gave the data to is also
deletes it in reality it's it's tricky I
have no idea what that particular
situation how that will play out
we'll find out thanks for the excellent
talk as our local courts going to
enforce these this regulation or
European tribunals or how will it work
I couldn't local courts so is it going
to be the European tribunals that this
or yes well it's both it will be in
local court but I think previously the
the data controller could choose where
was and they all chose Ireland where it
was very difficult for people to attack
some of the corporate of the controllers
doing that but now you can have it done
in your local area in Germany or
wherever you are and that makes it a
little bit easier to access the courts
for that there are each country has to
set up their own authority that will
help enforce the laws and that's
slightly separate to the courts but they
have to be well funded and that's
something that's also going to change
because the old laws were very lacks Lee
forced and especially with the the lower
fines it wasn't very convincing but now
because of the fines and the class
action and the the courts been chosen
everywhere then it makes it a little bit
easier to enforce it thank you for your
time I have a couple questions so the
first one is when it goes from a
directive to a regulation they're
normally the countries each country of
the vote put it into law
right and this is all EU members have
done that yes sir it applies to
everywhere all at once on the 25th of
May but the each country usually would
probably also add their own there are a
lot of sections where they're allowed to
add something to the the legislation but
I think only about four have done that
it hasn't really happened so much
Germany I don't think it's going to
happen in one month right unless you get
all the assembly man may or may not I
have no idea what's going to happen but
the regulation applies everywhere anyway
so they don't have to enact legislation
to make it happen it's going to happen
but they can choose to go further and
Germany have done that in some sections
and I think the UK have have done it as
well and France and a much or Italy or
something like that was the other one I
know about if I may I have a second
question yep a certain type of things
like let's say you buy something and the
sellers are required to keep
your information of you yes because
certain things are control yep
obviously in Europe guns are not there
on the list but things have to be kept
now when you invoke your right to forget
mm-hmm they are they required to remove
them because you know you have a big
conflict right there of course there are
exceptions and one exception are for to
comply with your local laws or for
accounting processes and things like
that so when you do a race and I should
have mentioned this earlier you're not
erasing all of the data you have on that
person you're just erasing the the
personal data that's maybe not related
to your accounting or transactions and
you do keep the other stuff and you're
allowed to keep the other stuff because
you need to have your systems your
accounting systems working and so on yep
thanks for your talk don't another talk
recently that talked about the using the
company's house data he start dating
somehow extend from exempt from the gdpr
a company house the Eternity house data
you mean by by for instance public
directors of the company because you
nobody can find it you know authorized
and that's the thing I think it's
similar to that so the personal data is
only for personal for natural like for
people for so companies are not covered
by this you can have any information
about them in any form or sense
the question was the directors I'm not
sure and I imagine no because there'll
be well I can't say the reason why but I
imagine not because an exemption that
would be dealing with local legislation
and things like that
let's say a country voted to leave the
EU how much uncertainty is there around
how much of GDP is going to to stay it's
up to the country who decided to leave
it what they're going to keep and I I've
heard they're going to keep all of the
laws at this time so I guess it'll be
the same as it is for now and that might
change assuming that the country does
leave
[Applause]